А я все дивлюся, де моя Маруся.
А я все дивлюся...
Бути художником — це означає бути людиною.
Бути людиною з великої літери.
А далі треба зрозуміти,
для чого саме ця людина існує.
Вона існує для того,
щоб залишити слід за собою.
Вперше я усвідомив це дуже давно.
А серйозно у сьомому класі.
Правда, я не мав чим малювати.
Олівців та акварелі не було, нічого не було.
Були квіти.
І якщо хотів щось кольорове намалювати,
то малював цими квітами.
Їхніми пелюстками.
Такими жовтими, як прапор України.
Десь в тата крав листочок паперу
і за допомогою жовтого кольору
перетворював його в такий ж.
Якщо мав жовту, блакитну та синю квітку,
то вже й мав фарби таких кольорів.
Мені подарували на ялинку
не дуже великий альбомчик в сьомому класі.
Він довго лежав, а потім я подумав:
«Ну чого він лежить?»
І мені прийшла в голову ідея,
що я зараз буду змальовувати з «Читанки»
портрети поетів та письменників.
В мене виходило.
Мене питали журналісти:
«Який найщасливіший день у вашому житті?»
Я відповідав, що той, коли я відчув,
що я вже буду художником.
Скільки я бачив держав за 20 років.
Звісно, коли подорожував з виставками,
бо я туристом рідко бував.
Шість останніх років з виставками.
Красиво, чудово, фантастика.
Але малювати не хотілося чомусь.
Тому що воно не моє.
От не моє.
Якщо красиво, то я любуюся.
Але рука у мене не піднімається.
Мені цього не потрібно.
Але коли я повертаюся на українську землю,
то я всюди бачу диво.
Вабить болото чи стежка в полі.
Погані дороги теж ваблять, я їх теж малюю.
Я вже дійшов до такого,
що маленькі грудочки землі малюю.
В моїх пейзажах присутній гіперреалізм.
Я, як бачу дорогу, землю, хочу зробити так,
щоб вона матеріалізувалася.
Так, щоб можна було б ногою на неї стати.
Або грудку взяти у руки.
Я побачив в Седневі, на Чернігівщині,
голі дерева у гаю на фоні неба.
Яке ж мереживо, яка ж то краса,
яка ж то графіка чудова.
Видно анатомію кожного дерева.
Я хочу і буду робити так, як не всі.
Я мушу відкривати свої горизонти.
Я був в Америці і там пейзажів не малював.
Під ту техніку ніякі фарби не підходять.
Ніде в світі.
Можна робити, але це вийде не той ефект.
Ці картини я робив ще радянськими фарбами.
І вони як висихають, то роблять мікрорельєф.
Через мікрорельєф, здається, що місяць світить.
Зимові пейзажі малюю влітку.
Це я так жартую, щоб не здавалося, що жарко.
Будь-які морози малюю влітку.
Оці червоненькі я намалював у Каневі.
Влітку, коли я купався там.
А ви згадуєте, як вони виглядають?
Це конкретний мотив, взятий з натури.
А картину я малюю вже не на природі,
а в майстерні.
І встановлюю погоду таку, яку хочу.
Ніколи я не починав малювати щось з назви.
Тому в мене багато картин не мають назви.
Але весь цикл я назвав: «Голос моєї душі».
«Голос моєї душі» —  це стовбур дерева.
Воно росте і пускає гілочки.
Кожна гілочка — це Марчучок.
Воно продовжує рости і я не знаю
скільки ще Марчучків народить цей стовбур.
Я не знаю, скільки у мене робіт.
Якщо перерахувати всі, то думаю,
що вийде більш як чотири тисячі.
Половина з них посіяна по всьому світу.
В радянські часи не було візитівок.
Я давав картину, як візитівку.
Ніхто не міг мені нічого зробити.
Я був заборонений.
Через те, що я приїхав зі Львова.
Мене зразу вважали націоналістом.
А найстрашнішим вважалося те,
що я втрутився в «священний» соцреалізм.
І почав його руйнувати всією своєю творчістю.
Я з дитинства дуже бунтівна людина.
Понад усе я люблю свободу.
Постійно мав справу з КДБ.
Вони вивертали та виривали з мене душу.
Після зустрічей з ними,
я впадав у тижневу депресію.
Це втрата часу.
Був випадок, коли я просто хотів піти з життя.
Одне слово з трьох букв мене лякало.
Аж так, що я хотів переселитися
на будь-яку планету і гризти там землю,
аби мене звідти випустили.
Це страшно.
Більшого страху я ніколи не мав.
Коли я показую друзям картину,
над якою я ще працюю, то вони кажуть:
«Ой, ой всьо, всьо, та вона вже готова!».
Я їм відповідаю, що вона здається готовою.
Там ще тисячі мазків треба покласти.
Вже коли я втомлююсь, я знаю,
що ще можу попрацювати.
Але буває таке, що втомишся і думаєш,
що вже ніби вона тобі подобається.
Картини завжди показують першими жінці.
В мене жінки нема, тому, хто перший прийде,
той і подивиться.
Я завжди слідкую за емоціями.
І мені ніхто не лестить.
Просто я їм так вже набрид,
в хорошому сенсі,
що, що б я не зробив, вони всі кажуть,
що дуже добре.
Моє ім'я вже знають у світі.
Я мріяв про це, я не жартую.
Художник ніколи не хоче бути забутим.
Він хоче, щоб з нього все,
на що він здатний, витягували.
Це ваші автопортрети на картинах?
Наприклад, в цій картині, в ромашках?
Це ви себе так уявляєте?
Не уявляю, це я лежу там.
Цю я намалював в Канаді.
Виставляв її в Філадельфії.
Підходять до картини дві панни і кажуть одна одній:
«Подивись, які гарні ромашки!»
«А чому він труп туди поклав?»
Я підійшов до них і сказав, що це ніби то я у раю,
мені дуже добре лежати на землі.
Люблю так лежати і слухати як трава росте.
Я — вічний мандрівник, прикутий до мольберта.
Ось хто я. І так все життя прожив.
Як учився колись, то хотів Сковородою бути.
Думав, що ходитиму з паличкою,
як він, і буду просвітником.
Навчатиму людей добра.
Слава Богу — відмовився від того.
Нікому зла не робити, а тільки добро.
І дарувати людям втіху. Ось моя місія.
— Дякуємо вам!
— А я дуже люблю, коли плачуть.
Кожна робота ставить переді мною якесь завдання.
І я ставлю перед нею.
Починається війна між мною і полотном.
І бувають такі полотна, що я не в силі їх здолати.
Я намалював одну картину, але це не те.
Проходить трохи часу, я не можу її тримати,
бо вона мені не подобається.
І малюю другу.
Даю відстоятися.
Я не можу на неї дивитися,
але мені шкода пошкодити полотно.
Думаю, що краще замалювати — замальовую.
Третю [малюю].
І плачуть люди від дива, від ностальгії.
Знають моє химерне життя.
Я жив багато де, але завжди повертався сюди.
Одна нога там, друга тут.
Так не можна, треба було пуповину розрізати.
Я того не зробив.
Не було кому це зробити.
Це могла зробити тільки кохана жінка,
якої в мене ніколи не було.
В 70-х роках була.
Я мріяв втекти звідси, тому і її покинув.
А слово «Нью-Йорк» було магічним для мене.
Марчук в 7, навіть в 6 класі знав,
що там проживає 14 мільйонів людей.
Через 45 років я опинився на тій вежі.
[сміється]
От і побачив.
Жити тут сумно, соромно і страшно.
І коли я про це думаю, то дійсно так і є.
В хаті пусто, нікого нема.
Художником завжди добре бути всюди.
Я перевірив себе в тому плані.
І чи можу я вижити за межами,
без друзів, без мови, без нічого.
Тільки з пензлем в руках.
На будь-якому острові, в будь-якій країні
я міг би жити тільки зі своїми пальцями
і пензликом в руках.
І безбідно жити.
Художник — це тоді, коли ти встав на ту стежку
і ти повернутися назад уже не зможеш.
Якщо ти хочеш досягнути того, про що ти мрієш,
то все, не шкодуй себе.